[Music]
she's done some [ __ ] just like galloping
see me see me see you where'd you go oh
you see it like as soon as i as soon as
i like got ready to turn the thing on i
heard
like from across the room and then she's
so [ __ ] funny
okay so we're starting the live stream
and i just got back from the oasis biker
bar yeah we're a little late man those
people were [ __ ] me up tonight
buying me all kinds of free drinks and
uh
i was like uh look i gotta go it's 5 30
and amy the bartender was like no no no
you got to stay till 6. i was like why
do i have to sit stay till six and it's
like my friend's coming she's gonna take
over for me and she's
and i gotta get she's gotta see you
i was like i was like what remember i
was telling you about
there's some girls that wanted to have a
damn gothic wedding and they wanted to
have somebody stripping at their
bachelorette party and everything right
yeah it was the [ __ ] uh
the bride the bride okay and [ __ ] that
so i had to stay until she showed up
she was cute she's like a taller version
of like air like like [ __ ]
uh a [ __ ] aurora she's like that
and same tattoos and everything on her
back and i was like you have to stand
some baby i'm not i'm not a stripper
it's just this right here it's trying to
get me anyway
she's looking for some other nights to
work and i was like she'd be great as a
[ __ ] bartender at mannequins and um
she was cool but
i had to stay till six until i met her
and then i left that's all it was
so i'm getting pulled into all this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and that's what happens
all over sunday yeah but i got a bunch
of free drinks and [ __ ] really um
a lot of old biker guys looking at my
[ __ ] buell lightnings and [ __ ]
they're going yeah that's cool bike but
talk about motorcycles mostly
so
the show was delayed and now we're here
to talk about scanners i mean only half
an hour so it's not a big deal now
here's the crazy thing
now i know that i said on friday night
so i said oh we're probably going to be
talking about george romero's monkey
shines because we had already seen that
at that point
yeah but then last night
we didn't go out and so i was kind of
like going i have hbo max because it
came free with my phone plan yeah and i
don't go on there like all that much but
last night for whatever reason i was
just kind of like i'm gonna go on here
and see i was looking for some movie but
i didn't find it but i was like ooh
what's this they had like a little
curated area by like amc not the movie
theater chain but the channel
it's all these curated classics and i
started looking through them like holy
[ __ ] they have like a [ __ ] ton of really
good stuff in there good stuff it's like
and there was like a [ __ ] ton of movies
like all kind of like ingmar bergman and
like all just all kind of like classics
and stuff and i was just kind of like
white crap yeah i was like oh man like a
bunch of like japanese movies like
alibaba and all this
stuff yeah and i was just kind of like
god damn there's like so many movies in
here that i want to watch or re-watch
and they had a bunch of david cronenberg
movies they had the brood they had the
fly and stuff like that and then tom was
like let's watch scanners because we
haven't seen it in a while yeah and i
was like well i was like i'm pretty sure
we already reviewed scanners but then
when we went back through my thing like
we hadn't watched like i thought we just
watched it like a couple years ago
and
which would you know which would you
watch
too i think we ended up watching
skinners too and being like and not
liking it but i mean we've done a bunch
of other cronenberg movies right we've
done shivers we've done the brood we've
done rabid we've done dead ringers we've
done video drone we've done the fly
we've done like yeah we've done a dead
zone we've done the dead zone so we've
done like most of the iconic ones but
for whatever reason we never got around
to scanners so i was just kind of like
well [ __ ] what's that
was a [ __ ] masterpiece went back and
watched that last night and i was like
god damn this movie's much better than i
thought it was
it's a paranormal
spy movie
okay it had a lot of really cool [ __ ] in
it yeah very much in the vein of a lot
of 70s kind of like conspiracy thrillers
you know what i mean it had ironside in
it back when ironside was young and that
[ __ ] was always creepy but in
this one he was [ __ ] really good he's
so great in this i mean actually he's
like the best thing about well other
than the head's bloating but it's like
he's the best part of this movie i went
back through and i was like i remembered
all these scenes but now i'm seeing them
as an adult i haven't seen him in so
long and i was like man this is some
[ __ ] cool
[ __ ] there's a lot of strong stuff in
this movie especially
the interior shots
where cronenberg is choosing to shoot
it's like a [ __ ] dead mall video it's
like urban exploration he's going to
these [ __ ] high-tech for the 1980s
very early 80s high-tech [ __ ]
locations
and [ __ ] old abandoned locations and
it just gives a [ __ ]
it gives a [ __ ] great feel to this
movie it's it's a masterpiece scanners
[ __ ] right go see that
i mean the story's tight man it's told
really good there's only a couple little
spots where the editing
kinda
falls a little bit short but it never
fails
it's it's always yeah it's slightly
saggy in the middle but it's just a lot
of movies have them yeah
and the thing that's amazing about this
is that i mean this was really david
cronenberg made movies before this
obviously he made rabbit and uh you know
and shivers and stuff but i think this
was the first movie that was kind of
like a big hit
and it was sort of like the first one
that gave him like mainstream attention
but the craziest thing about this he has
gone on record as saying this was the
most difficult movie he ever shot what
they were trying to do was they were
trying to get because you know how
canada used to have uh because a lot of
his early films were funded by you know
the the tax shelter thing yeah um so he
was trying to get that for this but the
deadline was like immediately so they
had to like put it into production
before there was even a script done and
before any of the sets were done or any
of the locations were scouted or
anything like that so pretty much the
whole shoot of this movie which i think
was only like a month or two
was he would get up super early
write the scenes yeah
and then like they would shoot and then
like he would go scout some locations
and then they would shoot you know what
i mean he did have ideas for this like
back in the 70s because i think he had
written a couple stories like there was
one called like like tel telepathy 2000
or something like that but he had like a
couple ones about like dueling telepaths
or psychics so he was kind of like
jumping off from that but
yeah this didn't even have a finished
script when it uh went into production
and you can't really tell that to be
honest some people are going like i
can't i can't wait to remember this one
and blah blah look
go see this
see it it's a masterpiece like i said
it's on hbo max i'm not sure where else
it is yeah you can see it for free or
[ __ ] red if you have hbo accident
it's kind of lacrosse
it's just it
it's kind of like an urban exploration
video and [ __ ] a spy movie
and it's just everything all happening
at once it's aged really well it's
really good
uh and some of the [ __ ] that cronenberg
has filmed
probably in the time that he filmed it
it didn't mean much but but over the
years it's aged out to where it's like
kind of
in a certain way become extremely hip
yeah it's amazing how kind of like sort
of modern this concept is i mean i know
that there was a lot of somebody brought
up uh the fury which was a brian de
palma movie um so you did have a lot of
like telepathic style movies like in the
70s you had terry and the fury and stuff
so this kind of goes along with that but
in some other ways the way that it sort
of sets everything up as
the psychics or the scanners being like
the next stage in human evolution
possibly that was caused by like some
kind of
uh drug that gave them this mutation
it's almost kind of like a little bit
like the x-men a little bit it has kind
of that kind of thing to it like these
are mutants are they good are they bad
drugs and the mutation what they're
talking about is phthalidomide yeah
which i'm actually a victim of flip
thalidomide my big toes were [ __ ] up
they fixed them
but that was thalidomide
and [ __ ] uh because my toes when i
was born it was like they were on their
side like thumbs so they [ __ ] cut
that [ __ ]
i was lucky to even have arms and legs
because the litamide will [ __ ] your ass
up yeah look that [ __ ] up and um so
they're talking about thalidomide but
what there's almost the
thalidomide making a [ __ ]
psychic ephemeral is the name of the
drug in the movie what's great about it
is that they've gone beyond the concept
of nation states and governments is that
it's [ __ ]
corporations yeah it's like corporate
warfare and it's corporate warfare and
corporations using spies to [ __ ]
track each other down and kill each
other it's [ __ ] great man it's
looking just very much ahead of its time
um and when i say it's ahead of its time
it's just that
no that was going on back then it's just
that the average
person thought that that was fantasy it
turned out it was reality the
you know [ __ ] the
the [ __ ]
industrial the military industrial
complex is exactly what they're talking
about that goes way back so the movie is
[ __ ] very cool very very cool and
it's it's i saw it when it was new
cooler now than what it then it was back
in the early 80s it's cooler now than it
was
so see you want to hear something
hilarious i remember very vividly
uh my parents when when i was little
now this came out in 81 right so yeah so
i would have been nine when this came
out obviously we didn't go to the
theater to see it but my parents used to
take me
and my little brother who was probably
only five or six at the time like we
would go to uh the drive-in
because you know it was kind of cheap
and a lot of times they would have
double or triple features or whatever
the weird thing about the drive-in where
we grew up
was that you know how a lot of times
you'll do a double feature or a triple
feature of movies that are like similar
like we're gonna do
three horror movies or whatever
they didn't do that um it was usually
like three completely different kinds of
movies so it was usually just kind of
like uh you know a comedy and maybe a
kids movie and then a horror movie and i
was just like i don't know if that's a
great idea but okay
so we had gone to this and i think the
first movie was maybe a comedy or
something like that and then
scanners was either the second or the
third one
and so it starts and we're watching it
like me and my little brother are like
in the back seat with our little
blankies and our little snacks or
whatever
and you know about 10 minutes into the
movie that dude's head explodes yeah and
my mom's like all right we're leaving
i remember the head explosion [ __ ]
thing going down when i was a kid and it
[ __ ] blew my mind and that was such a
that's still a great effect that was one
of the few things in the movie that
stuck in my mind when i was a kid
but now seeing it as an adult no the
whole movie is [ __ ] cool and it was
it was very much
cronenberg
[ __ ] master all right he is was very
much ahead of his time i mean he's one
of my favorite films back in the 80s
this was just sci-fi nonsense
you look at it now and you go yeah
that's reality
that's the way it looks well i can't
really blow anyone's head up by thinking
about it not yet but we're just talking
about
we're talking about [ __ ] um
corporations running [ __ ] and the [ __ ]
the weird [ __ ] that they do so well he
was very interested in i mean i kind of
feel like his
obsessions throughout most of his films
have been you know obviously like weird
sexual grotesqueries and like body
horror and stuff but he's also really
concerned about
it seems like the lack of humanity
inherent in
corporate structures so in governments
there's checks and balances but not in a
[ __ ] corporation that's like a cult
and they have money and [ __ ]
technology and they can do what they
want
and it's a dictatorship in a in a
corporation so that's that's kind of
what that's what he's talking about it's
worth a watch
well i mean all of the like corporations
that he has because like i said you saw
this in well not so much the brood
because i think that wasn't really a
corporation as more like a weird like
like a cult type of thing but it was
kind of like there's some overlap there
similar so like in this one essentially
you have consec which are essentially
the good guys kind of kind of
um although they do have a guy working
there who's like a mole and stuff like
that but then you have michael ironside
who's the villain who's like this really
powerful scanner and he started his own
company which what the [ __ ] is the name
of it like something amalgamated yeah
bio something something or other
molecule there's something like square
with the [ __ ] beaker with a beaker in
it yeah so it's like they all so it's
kind of like they you know there's
corporate espionage and like all this
other kind of stuff because basically
what michael ironside this character is
trying to do
is that
he's trying to i mean the drug that was
given to pregnant women that made people
scanners which is called ephemeral he's
trying to give that to everybody so he
can essentially make like a scanner army
and like take over the world and consec
well at least the guy like dr ruth the
guy that's uh you know ends up being i
don't want to like spoil it too much if
you haven't seen it but who who's kind
of like nominally the good guy he's kind
of trying to like prevent um the bad
guy's name is revic from doing that yeah
because so and then like the good guy in
the movie and let's kind of talk about
this a little bit because i kind of feel
like this is probably the most common
criticism uh leveled at this movie
so
hold on what criticisms were leveled at
this movie
yeah criticisms were little oh
my i'm gonna kick a [ __ ] in the
jaw well no i'm just saying criticize
this this [ __ ] is a masterpiece
it is yeah there's problems but it does
i mean it's not my favorite cronenberg
movie but oh man it's definitely one of
his best ones it is a good movie it's
fun i think my favorite one is probably
dead ringers but i mean i'm going to say
brood is my favorite but i mean that's
what i mean it's hard to pick they're
all good they're all good
was great there's always something like
he's always doing even his new one
crimes of the future was was really
[ __ ] good cronenberg stayed [ __ ]
strong through the whole thing and his
son i think is good we've seen one i've
seen one of his i've seen both of them i
liked him
yeah one he did one called brandon
cronenberg if you don't know like yeah
he has a son and uh possessor is great
and his other one his first one was
actually called antiviral and that one's
really good too
i saw that one possessor was good
anti-viral bait actually beyond 2b now
that i'm thinking about it because i
think i watched it not too long ago
you know yeah i mean he's definitely a
chip off the old block that's right but
i must say they're awesome yeah but what
i was gonna say was that one thing that
people that you know people that
would have one thing to criticize about
it a lot of people didn't like uh the
main well the main good guy i guess the
main good scanner uh who's played by
stephen lack
and
they thought that well he's just very
like kind of like a charisma void like
he's just kind of like robotic and stuff
and i think that that maybe bothered me
a little bit the first time i watched
this but when we were re-watching it
last night i was like well that's a he
did that on purpose because i mean they
kind of went into
why he was acting like that the whole
backstory of his character
was that he didn't know he was a scanner
yeah and he had just kind of like lived
on the street and just heard well he's
telepathic so he hears everyone's voices
and [ __ ] like and all their thoughts and
stuff like just constantly assaulting
him like at all times yes and he didn't
know how to turn it off and so he'd
basically been like living in the street
not knowing what the [ __ ] was the matter
with you see if you're a scanner
you're going to hear other people's
thoughts and you're going to [ __ ] it's
going to drive you crazy and you're
going to basically become a crazy person
like you're a schizophrenic yeah and
they went into that like they actually
even said that in this movie but that's
not the situation you're actually a
scanner you can [ __ ] read other
people's minds and then you can dominate
other people's minds kind of like out of
kind of like out of [ __ ] fire starter
[ __ ] with the father could push
people they're like that it's a lot like
that like you can kind of manifest some
physical [ __ ] too because it did seem
like some of the scanners that they were
really powerful could like set people on
fire or you know the main guy could like
speed up or slow down like other
people's heart rates yeah um you know
cause people to have like migraines and
that kind of so all this [ __ ] psychic
[ __ ] was an accident really it all came
from ephemeral okay and if you had
ephemeral it would kind of
cause your
the voices in your head to subside yeah
you just gotta see the movie okay uh no
i thought it was great i thought the
whole [ __ ] thing was great
yeah i mean yeah i really liked it too i
hadn't seen it forever we thought we saw
it recently but we didn't we saw
scanners two which is the pieces of [ __ ]
scanner one is the real movie and it's
it's great i thought it was a
masterpiece yeah i mean scanners it's
not perfect but a masterpiece doesn't
have to be perfect
it's just
the premise
and and and the the feeling behind the
movie it's got a really good tone
you'll see
well there's
especially if you're over the age of 30
ah [ __ ] that [ __ ] even a young person i
think would understand that this movie
is [ __ ] great it's creepy
well like i said i think that one of the
things that i actually always really
liked about cronenberg's movies is that
i really like his juxtaposition of
the clinical
with the
viscerally disgusting and the corporate
i kind of like i find that juxtaposition
very uh satisfying yeah i don't know why
uh but and i think a lot of other people
do too is probably why a lot of people
like his movies um
yeah it's just kind of like uh slasher
fred said the fly from 1956 or 1956 i'm
sure you probably mean 1986 deals with
the fear of aids yeah it does i mean it
could be aids or it could be cancer it
could be like any long-term uh illness
uh brian hackett lecker is here hi tom
and jenny i'm here you miss me hey
what's up
um dead zone says holy parish of doom
dead zone remains point yet another
solid early cronenberg film i love yeah
dead zone's great one of the best king
adaptations yeah i agree but uh slasher
fred said there was once a dead zone tv
series i think we did a review of that
because we have it we have it on dvd
it's actually excellent it's excellent
it's definitely worth checking out yeah
it's got all it's got all what's his
name and it's most studliest that is
studlius
what's that guy's name um wait now i
can't remember just just i know be quiet
for a second so i can think of it so i
can think of it yeah
you just got from the [ __ ] weird
science
yeah
um they got that buffed out later on
why can't i remember his name yeah uh
[ __ ] g michael hall mike anthony
alcohol i know i think of it in a second
he was skinny and gawky when he was
young and then and then he buffed out
and then like became a stud like i said
when you saw him and edward scissorhands
i was like oh goodness yeah anthony
michael yeah um but yeah i just uh
somebody said johnny the pillow popper
have you ever seen a horror movie that
you were not prepared for
mine was hellraiser and basket case
never saw the previews i was just
shocked i don't know like i
well the thing about it is like i have a
thing where i just like to go into a
hormone i don't i don't like to read the
synopsis
i don't like to anything i just so i
don't want to expect anything a lot of
that i just want to watch it and see
what happens to answer your question a
lot of it has to do with your age
at the time back in the 80s my dad took
me to see the thing
all right at sawmill square mall in
laurel mississippi
and when we saw the thing
okay
i my dad saw it first he saw it with a
date
and he goes and he goes back and i was a
kid then my teenagers must been 13 or 14
i don't remember
uh maybe i might have been younger he's
like you gotta see the thing you're
gonna love it i saw the thing and it
blew my [ __ ] mind yeah it was 82 when
it came 82. yeah that was it blew my
[ __ ] mind i could see that and um
we loved it loved it we saw it like four
times
me and my dad
yeah
because it was something that from our
point of view back in those days was
something that could actually exist
something that could come from the sky
i still maintain that the effects in
that absolutely hold up
yeah in terms of in yeah yeah in in some
ways they do it's practical effects and
it's an object that's like because that
always looks better and we're going to
see i like the [ __ ] i like the sequel
the thing 2000 i think was it 2011.
yeah i think it was 2011. i still like
kind of a prequel right it was a prequel
and the i liked it too yeah yeah i
wasn't expecting much but i was like oh
that was actually uh yeah the prequel is
very that was quite decent it was
supposed to be practical effects and
they made a bunch of practical effects
but then they went over the practical
effect practical effects with cga with
cg because they thought they wanted to
make it look like a new movie but some
have said that the that the original
version before they [ __ ] it up was
[ __ ] even better you know
but it doesn't matter i'm more of a
story guy i'm not really all that visual
i don't care as long as it looks as long
as the story's good then i'm happy it
doesn't have to look real
yeah i mean i'm not really concerned
like i said i'm a very i'm a very laid
back particularly when it comes to like
horror i'm a very laid back moviegoer
i'm just kind of like
you made a horror movie i'm gonna sit
here and watch it i don't have any
preconceived notions you know other than
the normal [ __ ] that people would bring
to it i don't have any pretty i'm just
going to let you
do your thing just do it and i'm going
to sit here and watch it
and
we'll see how it goes like so
and i kind of in a lot of the stuff a
lot of my enjoyment of the film is not
so much that's why i don't really like
to make kind of generalized statements
like it's like oh i don't like cgi or i
don't like this or i don't like that
because
it depends it depends on the context of
the movie sometimes
you know doing a certain thing sometimes
i like movies that are just all visuals
and don't really have that much of a
story sometimes i like a movie that kind
of looks shitty but you know has a
really great story i really get into the
characters or whatever so it's just kind
of like i very much take every movie on
on an individual basis this movie though
i was going to say how they did the head
blowing up scene oh here's the thing the
original cut of the movie
um
originally
the head blowing up scene which is
iconic maybe there's gifts of it all to
every time like somebody tells somebody
something mind-blowing they put the gif
of that there but um
so
that was actually
originally the first scene in the movie
so they showed it to
test audiences
and test audiences i mean this is 1981.
you didn't really see like heads [ __ ]
exploding
you didn't really expect that to happen
which david cronenberg was just kind of
like yeah we're gonna have like
somebody's head expo exploding like
right out of the gate
so audiences were a little uh taken
aback and they said well after that
happened they couldn't like really just
settle down and like get into the rest
of the movie so they actually had to
move that scene like
late until later on like 10 or 15
minutes in because audiences couldn't be
like will you expect us to like pay
attention to the story after someone's
head explodes that's not gonna happen so
that's what they had to do they had to
like move it but um i guess what they
did it was dick smith still like did the
effects on this who like i said he's a
[ __ ] legend and
they basically i think they built the
head out of like plaster or something
like that and they filled it with
just a bunch of like goop and crap and
like you know people's leftover
hamburgers and just whatever would look
good flying and they did it a couple
times and it's like it didn't work out
all that good so what they did was they
built this like darkened set like inside
a truck and then like they put the head
up there and filled it with all the gunk
and then like somebody like they just
laid behind it and shot it with
and it looks great i mean i love
everybody loves that scene and everybody
loves like the final psychic fight where
they're just kind of like
you know like squinting at each other
and then like all the babies all the
veins are popping out like blood
squirting out of the [ __ ] [ __ ] and
like the eyes kind of like start glowing
the final fight scared the [ __ ] out of
me
it scared this [ __ ] out of me and seeing
it again
it wasn't it wasn't as scary as i
remembered it but it was well done it's
very well done
like i said you have to approach it as
it's not
a traditional horror movie
that you would have seen in 1981 it
wasn't like a slasher it wasn't anything
like that it was kind of more like more
like a detective movie yeah it was kind
of more like i said it was more like a
conspiracy thriller like from the 70s
like like all the president or not you
know like some of the ones that we've
done before like the conversation or
something like that it was kind of like
that um this with the paranoia and these
kind of like competing because it
essentially is dealing with two
groups of
corporate powers corporate powers and
also like psychic
warriors essentially some of whom are
good and some of whom are bad and
they're like battling you yeah they were
security companies and they were making
psychic
warriors
and they were fighting each other
[ __ ] it was just cool very cool
it didn't seem plausible back in the day
but i look at it now like yeah hell yeah
it's kind of like [ __ ] um
kind of like halloween three
where you have a cup i mean that's
that's a little bit of an off the wall
thing but now that you say that yeah i
can totally kind of like halloween three
we have a company that's making
paranormal
paranormal masks to kill people
they squish their heads and make money
they're making [ __ ] psychic warriors
and they're they're above the nation
state in a certain way they're they're
a nation of state can't control them
they're mercenaries they're a
mercenary corporate power that can do
all kinds of [ __ ] weird [ __ ] and
they're fighting each other it's nothing
to do with [ __ ] the nation state
[ __ ] great i loved it i loved it yeah
but like i said even the i mean the
company the kind of main company this
consec yeah like i said they're not
necessarily good guys i mean they knew
about the um the scanner program they
had a scanner program contacts kind of
like ocp out of [ __ ] yeah well you
know they had the program but it's just
kind of like it wasn't really working
out it wasn't getting results they were
going to like actually terminate it but
then they found out that revic yeah who
you know had been he'd like drilled
holes in his head and yeah like the
memories to come out crazy and [ __ ] like
that yeah so he was like the bad guy but
then they found out that he set up his
own company where he's trying to like
give all these people ephemeral so that
more scanners would be born so he could
kind of like take over
then they said okay well we need to find
a scanner that's as powerful as him but
that can be persuaded to
come over on our side and like we have
to figure out like how to fight him
because none of the scanners that they
had because there were only what did
they say like 237
people that could do it sec was kind of
like a [ __ ] kind of like ocp out of
robocop they were a defense corporation
that was making
weapons psychic warriors they weren't
good or bad but there was another
corporation that was even worse that
they were fighting against that's really
what it is yeah and that's why they had
the character of cameron vale like who
was the nominal good guy like i said
because he was just he was essentially
like a blank slate character he didn't
know he was a scanner he knew that he
had these
powers but like i said he was just
essentially like a street person because
he'd grown up with no knowledge of well
he thought he was crazy of his origins
and he just thought he was crazy because
he heard like voices in his head all the
time yeah but the psychic cops were
watching him yeah
he's down in the mall [ __ ] with these
old ladies with his mind well he just
like sits there and he's jumping on the
book somebody left a burger here
that brought me back to all these
[ __ ] dead ball videos if you liked
[ __ ] dead ball videos you'd love this
because [ __ ] can i say them all they
shot that in the beginning i kind of i
know it's very retro but i really liked
those red ceilings with it with the
light bulbs embedded in there i thought
that was kind of it was a dead mall up
in canada
that probably yeah
was shot in toronto quebec and montreal
as far as i know like like i said that's
where cronenberg shot almost the whole
mall concept [ __ ] trips a lot of our
generation out because we thought that
was the future and that [ __ ] is now the
past okay where you have a [ __ ] city
downtown area in covered by a ceiling
and with air conditioning in it
replacing downtown
but not none of that is a reality
anymore
it's just weird how reality has evolved
you know
the [ __ ] that's this movie's all
about that if you watch this movie
you'll you'll know what we're talking
about
and go see some [ __ ]
ghosts go see some
some uh [ __ ] uh
urban exploration videos on youtube and
you'll see
it's just it's great it's a masterpiece
if you ask me
i mean like i said it's not my favorite
cronenberg but
the thing about it that's
i don't even know if that'd be called
damage with faint phrase because it's
just kind of like he had so many [ __ ]
great movies yeah he had so many we
haven't even talked about like naked
lunch or anything like his newer stuff
like eastern promises
one of them is different yes so each
they're all trash which was also really
good i like this one and maybe the brood
and video drum those are my favorite
ones i kind of wanted to rewatch the
brood too but we already covered that
one so we didn't like we still see brood
again we haven't done naked lunch yet
though yeah guys we should probably do
naked lunch i haven't seen that in a
really long time the book was weird i
read it when i was a kid and it wasn't
it was weird and then the [ __ ]
cronenberg jumps in i'm gonna make a
movie about this that crazy [ __ ]
how are you gonna make a movie over
[ __ ] naked the cool thing about
cronenberg the thing i love about
cronenberg and this is kind of a similar
thing to what i love about lynch even
though they both have like a a very
different like approach to how they kind
of come at filmmaking is that
he like he comes up cronenberg comes up
with like the weirdest [ __ ] ever like
the most but he when he talks he seems
he's just very very like intellectual he
thinks a lot about like
what he's doing what he's pretty he's
very like literate in the language of
film and he knows exactly what he's
doing and the emotions that he wants to
evoke cronenberg if you're out there if
you're watching this video i love you i
do you're you're a weird bunker i mean
tom tom's drunk and everything i'm drunk
as a [ __ ] but i'm looking at nah
i do love you [ __ ] you you got some
weird [ __ ] that you come up with i love
it i do understand i love weird i mean i
love this thing i love weird do you know
that i understand it and i appreciate it
but you're a weirdo like i said he's a
lot more clinical and calculating yeah
whereas david lynch is more like
yeah
emotional and like um
very very like jungian like he just
wants to do stuff that's like dream like
and he's just kind of like well people
will find meaning in it i'm putting all
this dream imagery up there so
but i i love them for
similar reasons they're doing like some
weird ass [ __ ] but
you know [ __ ] man they're kind of like
coming at it from a different way yeah
uh holy parish doom says crash haven't
seen that in quite a while yeah i
remember seeing that i might have seen
that at the theater now that i'm
thinking about it i saw a lot of
cronenberg movies at the theater because
i was a big fan of his in the late 80s
and early 90s you know when i was old
enough to go to movies by myself um so
yeah so i saw that another one i kind of
want to rewatch is spider because i know
i remember liking it but i know that a
lot of people that are a lot of people
that are even big cronenberg fans like
really did not care for it and i
remember liking it but i can't remember
all that much about it so i really want
to like read anyone's in there saying
this is better than the brood i'm going
to say no they're about the same well
it depends on what you would buy
i like the brood better but i'm not
saying that it's a better movie than
scanners the brood's a weird idea and
[ __ ] i'm i love all that [ __ ] yeah
it's not about better it's just it's
different
it's different well like i said every
single one of his movies but well the
thing that's cool about it is that you
can tell like he has
a particular style and a particular set
of obsessions that has carried him
through like through all of his movie
but all of his movies like have
something different to offer yeah which
i think is great danny rowling said a
history of violence is my favorite
cronenberg film see that's also a great
one that's also a great one now you
probably haven't seen most other than
other than crimes of the future you
probably so you haven't seen eastern
promise you'd probably love easter
promises yeah honestly um you should
probably see that
um
yeah i only know old cronenberg yeah i
haven't seen it i mean he's yeah i mean
he's still yeah making movies obviously
yeah and he's what in his 70s 80s yeah
he's got be i don't know but yeah so
good though somebody mentioned
dreamscape
i've been wanting to do
uh a movie retrospective on dreamscape
for a really really long time i think i
put it in the poll a couple times but it
never wins
because i saw it on cable like all the
time back in this i think it came out
84. and i've been wanting to you know it
i saw it so many times back then and
it's just kind of like i never got
around to doing i've been really wanted
to like uh re-watch it so maybe we'll do
like a matinee on it one of these days
um
yeah better than the yeah like i said
it's i'm not gonna like be mad
like whatever
cronenberg movie people pick is their
favorite or whichever one they think
because all of his [ __ ] is so good or at
least interesting
that
honestly whatever cronenberg movie you
think is the best one or your favorite
one i'm not gonna argue with it i
thought it was all good
that's what i mean it's all good yeah
i've never seen a bad cronenberg flick
they're all good that's what i mean well
that's the great thing about him and
like i said it's a great thing about him
that's the great thing about david lynch
that's a great thing about people like
that it's like even when they put out
something that you don't
love it it's still
really interesting everything i've seen
from his son was good too yeah same so
yeah and he understands his dad's style
they're good like i said they're very
genetically similar
it's like they come up with like the
same kind of [ __ ] he knows the corner
brick stock
well and like i said i don't think
maybe we talked about this a little bit
when we talked about possessor
but
i don't even think it's so much oh you
know cronenberg's my dad so i'm going to
do some cronenbergian [ __ ] like in my
movies but it's just like well they're
related
and he was presumably raised by his dad
so you're gonna be kind of similar to
your family member in some way so
they're gonna have the same kind of
proclivities as their dad i don't think
it's anything well it's just kind of
like a people piss and moan about like
joe hill oh his writing seems like
stephen king i'm like well
stephen king is his dad so
that's what i mean he's got his own
thing going on
everybody does but it's just kind of
like obviously you're going to be
influenced by that because you grew up
around it cronenberg father and son i
gave it a thumbs up
yeah give it a thumbs up it's good thank
you thank you
well they were both good
we saw this movie yeah
you should like i said you should
probably watch antiviral too you might
like that a lot too i think i watched
that a few months back but that was his
first one antivirus
his son is different he's not copying
he's different but yeah he's got like i
said he's got his own thing going on
it it has it it's evolved a bit but it's
still it's good it's good if you like
his dad if you like the dad you'd like
the sun
it's similar i'm [ __ ] drunk
we gotta [ __ ] shut this [ __ ] down
how much time do we have what are you
talking about well we've been on i'm
gonna make it 40 minutes i'm going to
make it something to eat yeah when
you're ready all i have all i've had
today was a plain omelette and that was
yeah hours and hours ago
[Laughter]
me too same thing i'm making some beat
okay uh holy parachute doom says same
spider and history of violence are the
last i've watched i'm gonna rewatch
spider and i think there's a couple of
his newer ones that i haven't seen
but
i don't know there's we've done a lot of
cronenberg movies but i feel like
there's a bunch we haven't done that you
like i said that you might like you
might like eastern promises you might
like existence yeah i remember seeing
that one in the theater
actually if you liked crimes of the
future the new one yeah it was good it's
good uh you'd probably like existence
because that had a lot of the same i
mean it wasn't exactly the same but it
had a lot of the same kind of like touch
it was me jenny and one of the dudes
watching watching the new crown on brick
flick yeah what was it called existing
crimes of the future of the future and
we loved it and after it was over dude
was like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did
i just watch
and he's like yeah yeah he was on a
walker and [ __ ] he was like yeah okay
yeah there was literally one old guy one
old guy in the theater
one old guy understood and i'm like it's
cronenberg man he's like yeah that
[ __ ] what's he doing
[Laughter]
i like that he kind of returned to his
because like i said with the eastern
promises and history of violence those
didn't they aren't like the visceral
horror stuff that he's kind of known for
but crimes of the future kind of went
back in that direction it's like hey you
want another like stomach vagina we got
that for you you know what i mean so so
i like that i appreciate that he's like
returning to his roots with the body
horror because i i kind of like that
although like i said i did like his
psychological stuff too because dead
ringers didn't have a lot of the body
horror other than the you know
instruments for operating on me and
women there's that kind of thing but
you know there's that what do what are
you doing just male 1 okay
[Laughter]
man you are drunk you sure you're going
to be all right i'm fine fine
all right
all right just molestation all right all
right so we gotta go make something to
eat before he decides he's gonna
do whatever he's gonna do yeah so what
we've got we got to watch tonight we got
to do [ __ ] uh i was going to say
tomorrow is monday which means you guys
it's a haunting mondays got a haunting i
think that we're going to do late club
horror because i know a couple of people
asked about that one like i said i know
a couple people have recommended other
ones that i write all those down but i
think we'll do late club horror because
i have had a couple people ask about
that one and i think there's a lot of
outside info about that uh haunting as
well so
you know so be sure to be here tomorrow
at 6 00 p.m
eastern standard time we're gonna be
talking about a haunting
the late club horror yeah so we're gonna
watch that today and we might watch the
new like predator movie too like tonight
we're those in there giving us thumbs up
it's okay willow hey there you go all
right so we will see you guys again
tomorrow have a good rest of your
weekend